44 seconds of logos birds fly away to
signify danger cliche also chimps are
terrible about knowing when humans are
in their jungle I'm gonna get one shot
one shot is all I need you only get one
shot one shot is all I need cliche
monkey decides to freak out and break
loose at the exact same moment James
Franco is pitching the sensitive money
people on funding his monkey drug we're
ready to move on to the next phase human
trials yep medicine companies definitely
go from one successful Monkey Trial
directly to human trials this is totally
legit these guys should have way more
training expertise and common sense than
to do this these are discount actual
monkey scientists guards full-on murder
the ape with people in the room they
don't have tranquilizers also security
guard shoots potentially dangerous
monkey instead of sleeping or sleeping
know everything about the human brain
except the way it works Oh stuff it he
knows tons about how the human brain
works you're just looking for a lazy
zinger oh come on they get a bunch of
wild apes conduct millions of tests are
there with them every day for hours and
hours and they didn't know bright eyes
was pregnant
also this might be something that would
be difficult to spin with investors but
seems like if you've got a drug that can
make billions of dollars admitting that
you didn't know the egg was pregnant and
that that was the reason she went crazy
would turn it around in time certificate
of appreciation monkey conveniently
bonds to human just as human is about to
kill monkey right away Caesar displayed
hello there he's just gonna start
narrating like we haven't sat through 14
minutes of movie already also three
years later he kept a monkey hidden in a
residential neighborhood for three
fucking years and no one ever looks at
their neighbors windows ever and please
just pretty long will carries around a
chess piece so that he could reflect
dramatically on this point while
recording his notes scientists running
out of time and patience with his
father's disease tests his theories on
his own flesh and blood
stealing is only wrong when you're not
motivated by Alzheimer's so wait the lab
isn't getting funding to produce this
drug anymore because of the brighteyes
incident but still produce large
quantities of it anyway he steals these
vials but the lab never does inventory
or anything because no one ever notices
they're missing hey didn't the nurse
quit after the last outburst who was
watching daddy Rodman all day while his
son was at work stealing medicine the
chimp open window causes no concern for
will even though there's a wandering
chimp in the house also no surprise open
window allows Caesar to escape during
crucial part of the plot also monkey
only notices open escape window after
ignoring it all night long
guess it wasn't time to escape
yeah these are can't gone far how the
fuck do you know you can't have gone far
piano man won't happen again
there might a Walt Carbon Copy asshole
neighbor who's carbon copy also
sweatbands
he likes Frieda Pinto is not my
girlfriend wife and mistress in this now
just match my online dating profile -
were already Andy Serkis isn't winning
an Oscar in this scene brilliant
scientist drives a woody that's not a
sin I just wanted to say the word woody
so for five years Will's been taking
Cesar to the redwoods and this is the
first time there's been an incident or
anyone who has ever noticed a freaking
chimp being taken into the redwoods
see this is where I work no one here
will see you a monkey in this car in the
parking lot because scientists are
unobservant haha original Planet of the
Apes reference mustang owners are always
leaving their car doors open with the
keys in the ignition it's a very common
problem this honking driver is oblivious
to the absolutely amazing terrifying
scene directly in front of him it's
animal control not an ambulance right
Animal Control transports dangerous
monkey in van with no restraints
whatsoever is it bad that I knew the
evil animal shelter guy was going to be
Brian Cox before I even knew he was in
this movie
thank goodness San Francisco has a
closeby monkey sanctuary handy otherwise
this movie would have been a lot of
driving monkey Truman show you know I
don't see a ring on that finger five
years dating Frieda Pinto and you
haven't married her hell it'd be a sin
if it was five months
hey Tom you know that character malifaux
me you play in the Harry Potter series
just do that that's racist now you
hardly have a show so is there a reason
why the business minded Jacobs has kept
him on the payroll
especially after the disaster in the
beginning of the film hell they nearly
fired him on the spot then the 112 is
dangerous well and it doesn't work also
did he not ever tell his boss about how
the evil drug jump was actually just
protecting its baby
did he not ever start work on 113 or any
other new drug I'm trying to figure out
how he's not fired after the 112 was
scrapped and he was told to start over
but never did and that was years ago I
choose my father with it does one
brilliant scientist isn't fired
immediately his boss finds out he stole
a three-year-old drug and gave it to his
father I'll give you whatever you need
Medical boss just believes his
scientists when he says his dad was
cured with stolen drugs and orders new
testing without actually verifying that
the drug actually works by looking at
any data because big money decisions are
always made that way aerosol deliver and
play they used to give the monkeys the
112 by injecting them but with the 113
they have this fancy Green Goblin
aerosol delivery chamber
system which is only so they can infect
the snarky lab assistant guy and have a
cool everything goes wrong moment that
is a pink sweatshirt he just ripped off
Caesars body cleaned like he was doing
the tablecloth trick not possible what
that EEP said is racist Draco ex machina
guy who sneezes blood tells no one and
doesn't go to the doctor so that he can
die later in the story we they went and
grabbed his ripped sweatshirt from the
main ap yard and returned it to his cell
why hey girls let's go pound some beers
at the animal shelter then that sound
like a place where everyone has fun and
gets laid he's Cornelia haha original
Planet of the Apes reference I'm rooting
for Caesar but there's pretty much no
way he could have taken this knife also
how did he figure out what looked like a
regular bottle opener also served as a
pocket knife oh now you're gonna seek
help about your medical problem Jesus
this asshole always around also
convenient asshole comeuppance cliche
will gives up way too quickly after
being rejected by Caesar I mean we know
Caesar has moved on but will doesn't
Caesar wins over all the Apes with a bag
of chips ahoy we interrupt this Planet
of the Apes reboot to bring you the
beginning of 2001 how did this asshole
get in the house without breaking
something or are they still leaving
windows and doors open in this house
thank God will kept all that 113 aerosol
in his fridge after his dad died jumping
on a Mustang makes the grill fall off
because Ford how did Caesar get back
into the animal shelter without being
seen remember he had to go out through
the glass dome thing and he slid down to
the ground that's way too high and slick
to climb back up even for him sure I
guess he could have walked through the
front door
it's not like the landings are
incredible at their job or anything how
did Caesar know that this would work a
human being in his position looking at
strange cans in the fridge wouldn't know
for sure that jamming a knife in the
cans would create a slow enough release
that rolling the canisters down the hall
would infect all the Apes dude sees Apes
totally conspiring but so the movie can
continue shrugs it off I guess after
Franklin couldn't get in contact with
will that one time he totally gave up
forever and never used a phone or email
or anything explaining his condition
haha Charlton Heston for filthy mudblood
am i right ok then awesome I'm taking
ass in off for that right there also
Caesars gonna count to five and then
he's gonna start beating the shit out of
you over a ping billfold Caesar does
what Harry Potter took eight movies to
not do apes escaped Detention Facility
and procreate to triple their numbers in
roughly two hours Apes moving through
the trees remove roughly 90% of all
leaves no worries I know where he's
headed cliche this place has infrared
security cameras are you kidding me
also scotch tape dispenser fits in
perfectly with high-tech security
workstation sunglasses indoors are you
seriously trying to tell me that Caesar
stomped on his way to jens's to draw
graffiti wait he was just walking from
the underground employee parking lot and
now he's in the lobby like he just
walked in the front door cool shot but
what was the plan
hey guys after we destroyed the building
let's form a multi-tiered stare down
offensive well if Jacobs had gone on
vacation what if Jacobs had gotten a
phone call not to come in how long were
they willing to wait also what was the
point of that
hey Jacobs you're an asshole okay
everybody now let's get the fuck out of
here and not one of these Apes chased
after Jacobs or ran out the same exit he
did so we see the animal control vehicle
in the background here but in the next
shot the officer is already shooting a
net at this lone ape in the middle of
the street and all the freed apes in San
Francisco decided to hang back and save
this one ape look I know they're smart
and all but they're just wildly running
through the streets how do they even
begin to know there's one lost chimp
about to get captured by Animal Control
also it doesn't seem like killing is
exactly their style
I didn't kill Jacobs even though they
had a huge chance to do so but here they
keep throwing spears at this dude hoping
he dies a grisly death I suppose manhole
cover only goes halfway through wimpy
car windshield when really both these
cops ought to be dead traffic on the
Golden Gate Bridge is conveniently
stopped already so that there could be
hundreds of people in harm's way when
the Apes come through the bridge how the
hell can you know that from here if you
knew they were going to the bridge why
didn't you chase them down while they
were kicking it on a trolley why didn't
ya my roadblocks set up on the south
side before they even got there how the
hell did these assholes get on the
bridge this attempted murders somehow
different from all the other potential
murders they could have committed during
the escape why didn't all the simians
take this route it's the safest spot on
the whole bridge Caesar is pretty damn
smart but I think he missed a golden
opportunity to use this bridge the right
way fog rolls in at just the right time
to make it hard for the cops to see the
Apes okay great so they formed the cops
and totally got the drop on this
roadblock but there's absolutely no
reason why they need to engage them in
any way they could have sneaked past
them in the fog and not even risk
getting shot in fact since they have a
rule about not killing anymore this
attack seems pointless
oh okay I guess this murder is fine then
this is for King Kong or something bad
guy somehow survives fiery helicopter
crash because it's not cathartic enough
for him to die unless the angry drug
1/13 test ape is the one doing it my
mother always said if you can't say
something nice while dying you shouldn't
say anything while dying at all a bunch
of smart apes that just destroyed San
Francisco we're now taking residence in
the redwoods I'm pretty sure that's the
cue for the US government to start
bombing Redwood National Park take that
nature
maybe they sure to call this rise of the
12 monkeys ever since cinemasins began
the most requested thing has been TV
since and now it's a reality click the
link in the description below to check
it out and now the audio outtakes
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen I'm here to tell
you a very strange story the story of
our adventure in pursuit of us savage
beasts and now ladies and gentlemen I
give you
what would the side effects violence
aggression and insanity we need to take
the whole line back to formula
and what we shall be your friend is and
ah
[Music]